[Music]
I want you to make me
[Applause]
yeah looks like Adele came to the Super
Bowl for one person only Rihanna I can't
believe I even said yes yep the singers
all access account made it clear she was
there for riri's halftime performance
a very hot football team yeah the
shovel's gonna bring out celebrities
Adele she's ready alongside this viral
clip of Adele seemingly shushing the
crowd her official page writes everyone
be quiet Brianna is about to perform and
it's no secret Bella I'm the biggest
Riri fan like I love her back in October
the Grammy winner hit up a Halloween
bash and when the DJ played riri's 2010
hit
Adele got down on the Dance Floor
[Music]
it's been a complete Whirlwind it's like
it's so much fun and just like the rest
of the Navy Adele's patiently waiting
for new music from Rihanna do you have
someone that you missed you go I'm
looking forward to that yeah I was very
excited last night because there was
some teasers for Rihanna's new record
and I am I'm on the edge living life on
the edge waiting for in a good way
you're still gonna get music from me oh
but the fandom goes both ways between
the ladies in 2012 Rihanna shared with
Jonathan Ross the time she only went to
an award show to see the British
Superstar but really I came to the Brits
just to stalk Adele it really was
nothing about me it wasn't about the
Brits it wasn't about the performance it
was really just to
see Adele again I saw her at the Grammys
I mean I love her and does she know the
depth of your feelings for her she has
no idea so the Love's all around and
that is why Adele's fangirling
[Music]
comes as no surprise